if you're over here what would you guys
like to hear a wrap a hand up so polite
yes hello fellow white man what would
you like a a rap about
you're a priest who just got caught with
a small boy ah my priest who just got
caught with a small boy amazing stuff i
i'm an atheist and i was brought up
church of england priest didn't really
care but uh i'll imagine that i was
molested yes so
my priest who just got caught with a
small boy yes whiskey
whiskey rye
may i ask why you say it that way round
is that a type of drink rather than rye
whiskey which same thing
okay why do you say it back to front i
don't know because you've had too much
rye whiskey is that why
whisky wrap
great do you prefer rye over over corn
right yes yes good cool cool whisky rag
and my priest who just caught the small
boy this is let's come to this side room
would you guys like a wreck about hockey
ice hockey hockey ice hockey thank you
for clarifying
we do we do prefer field hockey in our
country of ice hockey it's usually
played by girls in skirts
whereas in your country in the country
north of you it's played by men who
aren't intelligent
in big gloves so they can punch each
other right okay so ice hockey whiskey
rye priest who is just being caught with
a small boy let's come to the the middle
of the room you guys we've neglected you
what would you like a rap about morris
boris johnson um yeah for those who
don't know he is our prime minister he's
a a terrible philanderer and uh
inept leader
what about boris johnson let's be more
specific
his politics boris johnson's politics
okay cool yeah i feel like you're like i
don't really know much about this topic
chris
you could have said you know his public
school education you could have said his
job at the spectator no his politics his
women oh my gosh boris johnson's women
okay cool
well okay well we've got okay his
politics is women and his hair this is
you know hit pause about guns and
[ __ ] and blame boris johnson's about
politics women and hair which is you
know one of the matches so to remind you
whiskey rye a priest caught with a small
boy in boris johnson's politics women
and hair and our other one was
[Music]
of course ice hockey yeah the the most
exciting
well that's did you just say aerosmith
shut up
taylor swift okay okay no one would ever
confuse her for aerosmith
um okay cool well let's uh let's do a
wrap maybe we'll throw those in um if my
lovely band can serve me up some hot and
steaming beets
as we say that would be lovely oh gosh
just sit back and marvel at the delights
of this
the symbols the the base this is going
to be lovely
okay where to start
where to begin tell you what look let me
do you a little things we'll do we'll do
like 10 seconds up top about taylor and
let's uh let's do this cool
i've gotta take your suggestion and
you're angry at me after taylor
recording the albums and get the masters
she sold them off to black robot scooter
brawn maybe she was waking up one
morning she saw there's a real market
for re-recording red or 1989 pretty hair
on her head similar in color to yours
yeah it's blonde but let me say i prefer
the aerosmith song anyway it doesn't
matter blonde hair i see a guy with a
fat face and he don't care he's like
hello there tv yes i'm on them my name's
boris sir named johnson they're in
number 10 get a lot of [ __ ] because i'm
really quite weird when it comes to
politics conservative by name
conservative by nature if you want to
shag my wife well i wouldn't blame you
her name's carrie simmons yes we've got
a baby coming out soon i've impregnated
ladies in many different countries many
different years i still won't admit how
many there are i think there's maybe six
or maybe seven if i met a man that guy
is so unpleasant he's like oh yes i'm in
charge of england but don't worry i
don't understand and i bring some
horrible pain and horrible cuts let me
move over here and get a nice cup little
tumbler it's kind of risky to go away
from the corn but you choose the rye for
your whiskey you pick these yeah maybe
you mull it over get the little green
label on the bullet asking you why risky
why you're so drunk can't pronounce the
words proper lie properly still spitting
out anyway yeah your hand up armpit on
display i get crazy when i drink all the
bourbon the rye flavor is burning i
prefer some ever so fun i will never
stop how do i light my rye whiskey on
the rocks on the rocks what does that
mean here's my advice it's a bartending
term and it means on the ice like some
guys with some gloves the guys with the
sticks they're like you're a [ __ ] ah
your [ __ ] i'm coming over here unhand me
sir i'm a polite man from canada it's
where they all come from north of the
border but the russian ones coming up
and cause the disorder they're like
hello my name is vladimir you're in luck
i will hit you in the face and then i
run away with puck i take it out of the
stadium i can't stand me i win the cup
the stanley i've never watched a single
game in my life i would rather eat a
popsicle that's nice ice that's the fun
thing to do gives me that relief when
i'm out in the sunshine spying that
priest in the corner i say whoa he stays
around the area in the vicinity of the
playground why are you there father you
should run away yeah i think you'd
rather never be uncovered but he's there
starts blubbering saying oh i was
touching this young boy's ring but i
didn't mean to get caught i go away
father didn't you taught in the past at
a catholic school and you teach me
luckily he never reached me in that way
like the son of a preacher man i say ah
you're illegal i should impeach you man
so i call up the fbi and he's like no
down for solitary confinement he goes
but unfortunately beneath his robes he
smuggled young boys in beneath the
clothes i'm like oh [ __ ] back mr priest
we need to get him out put him on the
day release and he runs away yeah it's
hard to resist the urge for the child
like you're listening to swift by taylor
she's the best yeah risky to talk about
the kid touching but yay swifty
[Applause]
[Music]